right and the difference is is that like
your parent came over from Nigeria right
your parents came over from right what
I'm trying to say is that like she said
Caribbean culture is different okay my
mum came from Barbados
mom I won't work my mum wasn't working
class in Barbados I didn't grow up
working class
when she came to Barbados she was
working class but she still never raised
us as working class and when it came to
my son even though I was a single parent
like when you're saying that you were
outside on the streets and I wasn't
taught as a Caribbean person there is no
way on Earth I could be out on the
street no way even if my mom come home
from work even though she was at work I
couldn't be out on the street my son
when I was working couldn't be out on
the street every Club going
youth club whatever he was signed up for
when I was at work if he came home he
had to follow me from the house phone
and let me know I want to see the house
phone come up on the number
and if it's not up by a certain time you
get a certain time drop off you get less
time so my son never grew up as a single
parent he was never out roaming the
streets never
he always had good education he went to
all the skiing trips to school he was a
prefect in his school and the only
reason why he took that head boy because
he had learning disabilities and he
didn't realize what when you came out oh
they want me to be head boy you know Mom
why don't you be head boy because
you got going loads of meetings if you
approve it you can just tell them like
stop running and you've got power in the
hallway because he went the power and do
you think do you think majority of
Caribbeans like first Generations are
like your son yeah
that's that's statistically incorrect
that's statistically incorrect that is
statistically and I'll tell you and I'll
tell you what hold on hold on hold on
one voice One Voice
you spoke about education you said your
son was educated statistically in the UK
Africa Indians perform the best then
Africans and then at the bottom it's
Caribbeans and South Asians or Pakistani
and Bengali descent so what you're
saying is statistically incorrect as in
uh Caribbean men uh no Caribbean men and
girls and Pakistani and Bengali men and
women statistically from the last census
performed worse than working class white
Brits I don't know nothing about
statistics I don't talk from statistics
can I make my point quickly because then
you can go back to that my point is
sorry
so back to Auntie's point the difference
is you're talking about attainment
there's a difference so we're talking
about culturally you gotta remember
Caribbean people during uh I don't know
what they call that period but Caribbean
people are coming from a background
where they only were exposed to Rich
whites people so their standards were
naturally higher when they came here so
the way they look at the way
um they were raising their children and
the social expectations of those
children was very different and I know
people say oh that's irrelevant it's
very relevant so wind Rush generation
the people came here with a standard
that was never here for black people
before they raised the standard for all
black people here regardless of
attainment level
my grandmother's still alive look they
didn't black people from the Caribbean
Caribbean regardless of money didn't
come here with a poor mentality even if
they were from slavery background they
were around rich white people this is
the facts rich people they had what you
would call higher class expectations
regardless of the setbacks of the
British educational system they excelled
every person of color in this what
generation are you talking about your
grandparents I'm talking about the wind
Rush generation so this is Auntie's
generation
well okay but let me what I I never
talked about that General no no but what
about I asked the question do you
believe the majority of Caribbeans are
in that like boys in particular in that
situation the answer is
so from her experience in her generation
maybe but for this generation maybe not
because they took on British standards
they took on British ideologies and this
is the problem we're getting confused
attainment I agree you are correct I
work in a university and that's what I
do for a job I agree with you you are
correct uh Caribbean people perform the
lowest and get paid the lowest out of
all black ethnic minority groups if you
break it down we get the least but when
it comes to standards and the way that
Caribbean people carried our culture as
a whole is a fact so when we say about
being on the street and all this stuff
this is this is a new thing this is a
relatively new
thing for our culture what generation
did that we're talking about in the 90s
we're talking about in the our general
oh all right can I say something Our
Generation sorry can I say something
okay cool I'll just talk of my own
personal experience here see when I say
like outside and all these things yeah
yeah what what needs to be understood is
I'm again in mixed culture yeah so
everyone lives different I'm going to
school and my parents did what they
could did it that's why I'm not writing
them off at all but when I'm going and
I'm seeing
um I've got what's it lunch you got your
two pound a day for your main School
meal and I'm seeing Johnny's got a tenor
a day yeah I'm gonna see these things
naturally because I'm not around people
like me if that makes sense you are
going through I'm in a mixed environment
seeing all of these things and now
naturally as a child you're gonna go
home oh Mommy can add it but now they
can't do that so
you might if they explain it to you
right and if you're that way in clients
you might listen and say you know what I
understand or you're just gonna say yeah
[ __ ] that the difference is
that's absolving yourself accountability
your parents still taught you right from
wrong but I never said once they never
yeah but I still was doing whatever I
did because remember this started off on
both parents in the household how the
difference can affect and I'm just on
the others I'm just showing the other
side of what can still happen even if
you still have both parents in the
household still doing what they need to
yeah
and that's why I I hear your point but
it took me a long time for me to stop
drinking the left Kool-Aid in terms of
bro at the end of the day we're given
decision we've come we're not in Nigeria
or whatever countries that we are from
that aren't in the first world you're
not giving the same opportunities the
fact is we come here we're all given a
British education it's your dumb as [ __ ]
you can go get an apprenticeship as a
plumber and to earn 80 grand by the time
you stick in that profession for 10
years it's very simple if you stick at
something in this country you will be
successful if you stick it and do it all
the man that I know are complaining
Amanda in jail and they'll be like oh
the system's [ __ ] me bro I'm like Bro
you've been jail three times what the
[ __ ] are you talking about do good in
this country and good things will come I
agree with that I'm going to sit in
three years
worth of Education I think culture in
terms of what you're not saying it does
play a big part but sometimes it's not
always the case because like you said
we're all from the same sort of you know
what I mean we're from the same
background and me and him growing up you
know that for example obviously in-house
was different
culturally but as you said we're in a
British school and we're both in the
same thing so nine times out of ten
we're both seeing the same things we're
going to be brought up a similar way so
I feel like you're just a victim of
circumstance rather than culture
when you said we both been built up
differently culturally
you will find that a Caribbean persons
the way they've been brought up is
closer to yours than an African person
yeah I agree no I'm not saying that no
fall differently but what I'm saying is
that
it's totally different yeah oh then put
this way the way I was raised was like
how a white person was raised look how
is that how a white person was raised
you know going to school coming up when
he's talking about you know him only
having two pounds and wanting to come up
with something yeah I mean that's alien
to me because I remember growing up with
other cultures and my sons my son's
friends and they were surprised that my
son had like you're gonna have biscuits
and you're gonna have this and it was
like really really strange for them but
it wasn't
it was a norm for me all the things I
remember like children there was a boy
called biscuit because every time he
came around my house he couldn't believe
that there were always biscuits there
and they couldn't believe that they
weren't locked away that they had to ask
for biscuits because I wasn't raised
like that my son wasn't raised like that
playing out in the street that's not a
thing it's not a thing but you know I
mean I I never I never played out in the
street if I played out it was like the
way they can see you and that was it
if I if I open that window and I'll call
you you're not there you know your ass
is mine and so certain things that I see
that African children going through and
English children go even now I find that
the standards that I was raised at when
I came over here the white people were
below me they were well below me as a
Caribbean person come here from Barbados
they were well below me because I went
to school in Barbados and then I came to
school here and I couldn't believe how
thick the children were in school I
couldn't believe it because what they're
learning in secondary school I learned
in primary school so it was totally
different and a lot of parents now in a
lot of old Generations they were like oh
you know what school's there we're gonna
send you to school you're gonna come
home that's it yeah my parents were
involved I knew the children's name I
went to all the meetings if something
happened to my son in the school I knew
about it if my son said oh this teacher
said this to me I'm down at school I've
had two other teachers like removed from
the school
um and a lot of parents would be like
they wouldn't the old people wouldn't
believe their children and wouldn't
support them so if they ever say an
African child went and said to their
their parent oh this teacher said this
to me it's your teacher
that's my mom that's my mom
what did you do yeah it was you my son
came home and my son said to me like Mom
this teacher says something to me or
this other I'm going to school I want to
find out what's going on I want to know
what's going on because it ain't gonna
happen you know when it comes to like
you know where people are playing out on
the street and people you say oh there's
nothing for the children to do well my
son was Raising you him and every year
in yum they bought a a list of all the
free clubs during the school holiday and
it was like my son was the only one that
used to go to all these clubs t-shirt
you know DJ mixing this and that and it
was where is he going everybody else is
hanging around yeah
goat and as a single as a single parent
I find that a lot of women raise their
children to be
wimps
they're too soft with their child
they're too emotional with their child
because I was raising a man I had to
toughen up because I had to toughen up
because I was not raising a boy I was
raising a man
so when a lot of people oh yeah I've got
the police coming around to my house no
my didn't happen my son went until he
was 21 till he met his father then to
start getting in trouble but as far as
I'm concerned either raise a man so I
don't take no responsibility for that
you're a man deal with it get on with it
yourself and I find the culture the
cultures are totally different and the
way you raise your children are
different because playing that industry
never happened not going to Pyramid this
evening the things that we had a
standard like I know African people and
they'd go and they'd have Gary for this
and then they have their dinner and then
that was it yeah you know Chris they
even had to take their lunch money and
buy crisp and chocolate to keep up with
their friends and then they go hungry
because they never had no lunch or
sometimes you see them there and they're
all hanging around and it was always
like the the African children that the
people you should share with them you
know we're going to buy chips we'll
share with you because I never had it
whereas as a Caribbean person
that never happened
and I saw a lot of it happening not just
to African people I saw it happening to
a lot of white children and in not white
single parent children as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible